[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos al debate de france
24 en español soy santiago ariztía en
reemplazo de mi compañero santiago lópez
y el primero de marzo el presidente de
eeuu habremos dicho bardem por supuesto
ofrecerá su primer discurso del estado
de la unión poco más de un año después
de su llegada a la casa blanca el
mandatario rendirá cuentas a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses sobre su
gestión y lo hará en medio de un
complejo panorama tanto a nivel nacional
como internacional y para analizar los
hechos que marcaron este periodo de
mandato y también el escenario en el
cual llega a este tradicional discurso
nos acompañan cintia ansón ella es
directora del programa latinoamericano
del wilson center de washington y
también está con nosotros jorge heine
profesor de relaciones internacionales
en la universidad de boston y también
autor del libro el no alineamiento
activo y américa latina' una doctrina
para nuevos siglos también es ex
embajador de chile en china ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar por supuesto en el debate con
sus comentarios y también sus preguntas
y lo pueden hacer a través de nuestras
redes sociales no se encuentran
facebook instagram y twitter estamos
como france24
y arroba santiago decía que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate este 24 esperamos
sus comentarios también sus preguntas y
comenzamos ya mismo como decíamos en
medio de una fuerte crisis internacional
se espera el discurso del mandatario
estadounidense un discurso que le dará
como se prevé más peso a la política
exterior debido por supuesto a este
contexto de invasión de rusia a ucrania
a bailén le tocará hablarle a la sesión
conjunta del congreso de eeuu mientras
rusia está invadiendo ucrania por eso
les propongo a nuestros invitados
comenzar por este tema cintia garzón
desde washington la capital
estadounidense
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos en
el debate de france 24 quisiera
preguntarle si quiere bueno que yo
bailen puede llegar a este discurso
sobre el estado de la unión
exhibiendo digamos su rol en el
conflicto ruso-ucraniano como un logro
no quizás se podría destacar el como
libre estado como líder en este
conflicto
bueno antes que nada santiago muchas
gracias por esta grata invitación que
tiene una tarea bastante difícil esta
noche primero porque normalmente se
habla de los logros de la administración
en estos tiempos lo que quiere hacer
hacia el futuro es buscar la unidad y la
aprobación de su nuevo candidato para la
corte suprema de justicia pero
obviamente los diversos eventos como
usted bien señala es en en ucrania hace
imposible no enfocar principalmente
en lo que está pasando yo creo que vamos
a enfatizar en los duro que son
el duro que son las sanciones de eeuu el
liderazgo que ha ejercido en
europa y otras partes del mundo
mostrando en el liderazgo de una
democracia contra la agresión
autoritaria de vladimir putin
muchos dicen que las sanciones no bastan
que hay que hacer cosas más fuertes
especialmente la línea de ataque de los
republicanos y el partido opuesto es que
no ha sido
suficientemente contundente la respuesta
y hay que mostrar a rusia que no es
posible continuar con esta invasión si
fuera chrome rusia nunca hubiera
invadido o sea son partes de la crítica
y de la crítica que se ha hecho entonces
quien tendría que mostrar la fuerza
la respuesta hasta orden de estados
unidos y también volcar a los temas
domésticos que también son muy
preocupantes y que han causado que sus
niveles de aprobación han bajado
sustancialmente
vamos a hablar con jorge heine quien nos
acompaña desde boston en estados unidos
señores gene cree entonces como
planteamos recién que se pueda esperar
que quizás eso bailen destaque el rol de
eeuu como un país líder en este
conflicto ruso-ucraniano
a ver al siguiente yo creo que el plan
original que nosotros habíamos escuchado
que el presidente de bailén tenía para
este discurso era referirse sobre todo a
la temática interna y sobre todo a la
gente económica y a lo que él ha logrado
avanzar en contra de la pandemia en
contra de cobain 19 y entiendo que sus
ayudantes y sus colaboradores han estado
trabajando muy fuertemente y él también
en obviamente presentar una nueva
versión del discurso incorporando toda
esta parte internacional y la la guerra
que hay en este momento en ucrania
yo creo que hasta ahora que el
presidente vayan ha logrado el objetivo
de aunar las fuerzas de la otan y sus
aliados europeos y generar una un frente
bastante sólido bastante fuerte en
contra de las acciones de rusia en
términos de sanciones en términos de
todo tipo de medidas que sean a tomarlo
yo creo que en ese sentido
ha demostrado liderato de conducción yo
creo que le ayudó mucho a él el hecho
que él desde muy temprano hubiese
señalado que su fuente de inteligencia
le señalan que habría un efectivamente
una invasión rusa de ucrania muchos
dudaron estos y otros dudaban de que
fuese una buena idea presentar estas
estas informaciones obtenidas de
inteligencia porque podrían indicar de
dónde la obtuvo en ese sentido yo creo
que tiene varios puntos a favor ahora la
gran pregunta naturalmente es qué es lo
que va a ocurrir en ucrania si la
situación no creerá se dilata y
obviamente eso va a ser un problema para
el presidente po ting si logra control
de ucrania en las próximas semanas diez
días una cosa así yo creo que la
situación sería distinta así que yo creo
que mucho depende de eso y es muy
temprano todavía decir sí que
efectivamente eeuu ha logrado resolver
este desafío de manera adecuada
considera usted que esto podría quizás
mejorar lo que es la posición de eeuu en
la arena internacional teniendo en
cuenta lo que fue el caótico retiro de
afganistán que según muchísimos
analistas expertos habría sido una de
las peores decisiones de bailén a nivel
de política exterior
a ver yo yo tengo hay un pequeño matiz
yo creo el temido de afganistán yo no
diría que fue una de las peores
decisiones yo creo que tal vez la
implementación de ella no fue de las
mejores pero en términos de la decisión
de dejar afganistán algunos dirían que
era la decisión correcta y era lo que
había que hacer pero como digo después
de ello obviamente acá esto constituye
otra prueba de fuego algunos dirían algo
más difícil que la de afganistán o que
en este caso se está enfrentando nada
menos que a cruz ya que es una potencia
nuclear que algo muy distinto a lo que
son los talibanes en ese sentido yo creo
que tal vez desde los años 50 y 60 en
que teníamos eso mano a mano entre ellos
kennedy y nikita kruschev que no
teníamos un enfrentamiento entre el
líder de los eeuu y el líder de rusia
como estamos teniendo ahora y mucho
depende de cómo esto se resuelva y cómo
se resuelven las cosas en el terreno en
ucrania misma
cynthia hudson volvemos a usted en la
ciudad de washington capital
estadounidense seguimos hablando del
conflicto ruso-ucraniano y el rol que
está jugando y que ha jugado a lo largo
de todas estas semanas estados unidos
eeuu ya dejó en claro que no va a
ingresar a territorio ucraniano eso no
va a enviar fuerzas tampoco no lo hizo
no envió fuerzas para repatriar o llevar
hacia eeuu a sus ciudadanos en
territorio ucraniano a qué atribuye
usted esta suerte del límite y que
costos y qué beneficios le podría traer
sobre todo tenga en cuenta no que en
noviembre se vienen las elecciones de
medio término
obviamente es un momento sumamente
complicado coincido con el embajador
fine de que el desenlace de la crisis en
ucrania va a definir mucho de que si el
mundo ve que ban ha crecido un buen
liderazgo o no yo creo que va
a quien a la capital para tomarlo está
bombardeando
edificios apartamentos
viviendas de civiles ya hay demandas
para una investigación de la corte
internacional criminal por los ataques a
los civiles bain
después de haber retirado de afganistán
no está diciendo que los estados unidos
tiene intereses vitales a defender en
ucrania de hecho ucraniano es un miembro
de otan que hubiera comenzado otro tipo
de acción y entonces dejar a putt en
ocupar
ucrania capturar tal vez asesinar al
presidente del inss que imponer un nuevo
régimen más favorable a rusia todo esto
podría ser interpretado como
en una derrota para la política de eeuu
pero no sólo de eeuu también de los
países europeos
yo veo difícil lograr un retiro de las
tropas de hecho yo creo que hay una vez
que han entrado y han
intentado
atacar a los centros de gobierno y los
centros civiles de la capital él va a lo
todo y
probablemente con las fuerzas ucranias
de ucrania no son tan capaces como los
soldados rusos y va a poder tomar
control del país lo que lo que pasará
después es una gran pregunta porque
muchos dicen que sería una guerra de
guerrilleros de guerrillas y de ucrania
contra las tropas rusas igual que había
pues ataques contra
en la ocupación de rusia en afganistán
en los años 80 que obligó a rusia a
retirar sus tropas entonces los costos
también para rusia son enormes pero el
costo para baile de una ocupación
completa total por parte de rusia y
ucrania es un gran riesgo político como
bien señala antes de las elecciones
legislativas de medio término este mes
de noviembre si te ha comentado a
ustedes que los costos políticos no
pueden pagar rusia lo puede pagar eeuu
en este sentido creo que quizás las
sanciones desde washington a moscú
también pueden volverse en contra
washington
no lo creo yo creo que lo lo difícil
para rusia sería
sobrevivir económicamente con los
niveles con el nivel de sanción que hay
y la unidad de europa con eeuu
incluyendo a países normalmente
normalmente que mantienen su neutralidad
como suiza en aplicar las sanciones lo
que si va a pasar es que los costos de
la energía del petróleo del gas en
europa y en el resto del mundo
van a aumentar y esto va a causar costos
domésticos en los países europeos y
también en eeuu pero luciano tiene
futuro económico con este tipo de
sanciones
transversales económicas contra el
sistema bancario
etcétera y los costos para rusia van a
ser muy graves pero otros también van a
tener que sufrir
costos económicos
volvemos vamos nuevamente de washington
hasta agosto para hablar para seguir
hablando con jorge heine porque hablamos
de bueno los costos de eeuu ha hecho un
gasto diplomático enorme a lo largo de
todo este proceso estamos quería usted
antes de una suerte de desgaste quizás
en su poder diplomático
yo no diría que haya un desgaste y creo
que esto es un poco el capital
diplomático es un poco como el dinero si
se utiliza bien se puede aumentar yo
creo que en ese sentido no ha disminuido
sino que ha aumentado puesto que ha
habido una reacción de los países
aliados al comienzo no estaba muy claro
que lo que iba a hacer alemania que
siempre hace un poco renuente a ser muy
duro con rusia eso ha cambiado por aquí
yo creo que eso ha aumentado ahora yo lo
que yo creo que es importante tener
presente es otro fenómeno acá lo que acá
estamos viendo es una situación en la
cual
básicamente se ha
producido una situación en la cual rusia
y china- se están acercando cada vez más
y han proclamado una especie de amistad
eterna nosotros lo que estamos viendo es
una recreación de lo que alguna vez se
llamó el eje chino-soviético que existió
en los años 50 y 60 y que básicamente se
quebró con la visita al presidente nixon
y de henry kissinger a china de 1872
en los últimos 15 años lo que hemos
visto es el resurgimiento de este eje
entre beijing y moscú y que yo creo que
con esto de las sanciones se va a
solidificar cada vez más algunos creen
que tienen le puede ayudar a rusia para
eludir al menos parte del costo de esta
sanción al de ahora que yo creo que es
otro fenómeno geopolítico que tenemos
que tener muy presente que es el
resurgimiento del eje beijing y moscú
habla usted de jorge de bueno los
vínculos entre rusia y china- históricos
también de aquel eje chino-soviético no
de la década de 50 y 60 ahora la guerra
deterioro aún más los vínculos entre
estados unidos y rusia vínculos que por
supuesto ya eran tensos no las nuevas
sanciones de washington a moscú a las
que recién hacíamos referencia creen que
estarían marcando ya un punto sin
retorno en estas críticas relaciones
bueno yo creo que siempre torno es una
palabra muy fuerte
rusia fue una superpotencia es una
potencia nuclear es el país con un
territorio más extenso que hay en el
mundo y no va a ninguna parte de veras
que es un país con el cual eeuu les
guste o no va a tener que tratar
entonces yo creo que es algo que hay que
tener aquí 3 presente hablaba también
usted de china jorge de lazos entre
estados unidos y china durante estos
últimos años se han ido deteriorando
durante lo que fue el mandato del ex
presidente de donald trump hubo una
suerte de
arancelaria no con conflictos
comerciales como telón de fondo sino es
una potencia por supuesto tiene lazos
estrechos con países de américa latina
donde ella hay muchísimos países de esta
región que están que es orientándose más
no en este eje sur-sur hacia china y no
tanto hacia el norte hacia eeuu podrían
ayudar en recomponer este escenario
reorientar yo esos vínculos quizás
bueno a ver yo dije lo siguiente yo creo
que lo que tenemos acá en realidad es el
estado de la segunda guerra fría para
todos los aspectos y por eso es que
nosotros en nuestro libro el elemento
activo y américa latina una doctrina
para el nuevo siglo que se acaba de
publicar lo que nosotros planteamos es
que acá hay que retomar los países
américa latina tienen que retomar una
página de lo que fue la política y no
alineados en los años 50 y 60 y tener
una posición absolutamente independiente
y fijarse en sus propios intereses y no
dejarse empujar hacia la bandera izarse
ya sea con un lado u otro
en esta segunda guerra fría que está
surgiendo obviamente los dos
protagonistas principales en esta
segunda guerra fría son eeuu y china
pero como estamos viendo en estos días
el rol de rusia no es un rol menor hay
todo un tema que ha surgido ahí está
denominado el rol de las potencias
externas en américa latina y algunos son
muy críticos de ellos o en los países de
américa latina deben vincularse con el
mundo entero incluyendo países como
china como rusia como otros y en ese
sentido nuestro canta miento del nord
alimento activo yo creo que ha tomado
renovada vigencia y de hecho ya está
siendo practicado lo que no hemos visto
en estos días con las visitas del
presidente argentina el presidente
brasil a moscú las visitas del
presidente de ecuador y la presidente
argentina a la inauguración de los
juegos olímpicos parecieran reivindicar
esta noción que los países de américa
latina están buscando un papel
independiente
en esta segunda guerra fría un papel no
alineado que nosotros hemos denominado
no alineamiento activo el sentido que
tienen que cumplir un rol pro positivo y
proactivo y no meramente que hace
esperando que otros tomen decisiones por
ellos
cynthia hudson en washington retomando
las palabras del señor jorge heine que
decía recientemente creo que estamos
ante una segunda guerra fría
yo creo que sí o sea los eeuu ha
definido a china como su principal no
socio si no no es enemigo necesario pero
competidor y hay en américa latina en
especial una preocupación muy grande por
los avances en el campo económico pero
también de cierta forma en
en las redes como 5g de china y los eeuu
podría
meterse y competir lo dólar por dólar
sino mostrando un interés de unir
esfuerzos entre esa propiedad o el bit
la corporación de financiamiento de
desarrollo para lograr mayores
inversiones
en la región pero de hecho es una
contradicción un poco con el deseo del
presidente y bailén de llevar la
inversión en eeuu entonces no quiere
buscar que las empresas de eeuu
invierten necesariamente y en américa
latina sino en la propia capacidad de
manufacturas en eeuu
creo que debería de discrepar un poco
con lo que acaba de decir jorge jaime yo
veo la
visita reciente del presidente fernández
de argentina y el presidente el bolsón
ario de brasil como algo criticable y
bastante ir a moscú durante
pues él
los principios de la crisis cuando hubo
muchas amenazas rusas sin movimiento de
tropas a países a la frontera de belarús
y crimea donde ella e invalidan
invadieron hace algunos años bueno estás
en el timing digamos el momento no fue
lo más propicio para ir y mostrar su
amistad con él ni de hecho lo es la
cancillería
argentina ha tenido que
tomar pasos atrás mientras bolsonaro
lo ha criticado la invasión yo creo que
el la afinidad para un líder autoritario
con para una persona como bolsonaro que
fue militar que a
avalado y ya
ha dicho
como diría su
cuál es la palabra que ha apoyado al
golpe al régimen militar de brasil y
vive en vladimir putin un socio o un
líder que hay que limitar entonces yo
creo que eso es realmente
criticable bolsonaro no ha criticado la
invasión mientras su vicepresidente la
cancillería han han han
pronunciado
contra la invasión y fueron criticados
por el mismo presidente bolsonaro yo
creo que es muy desafortunado y
comprendo totalmente el deseo de los
países latinoamericanos de tener socios
con muchos países del mundo
y
diversificar sus formas de inserción
global etcétera pero estos dos viajes en
este momento yo creo que fue
fueron una mala decisión
bueno continuamos con este debate y este
análisis de lo que de los hechos que han
marcado hasta el momento el mandato del
presidente de eeuu yo bailé vamos a
ingresar ahora en lo que es el terreno
de la política nacional más temas más al
interior de eeuu y empecemos con lo que
ha sido para muchos una piedra en el
camino del mandatario estadounidense
hablamos de la economía puntualmente
vamos a hablar de la inflación llegó a
los niveles más elevados en 40 años
quisiera ahora retomar el contacto con
jorge heine que se encuentra en boston
eeuu bueno jorge esto está golpeando
muchísimo el bolsillo de los ciudadanos
de eeuu qué herramientas tiene yo baiden
para contrarrestar esta tendencia
yo creo que acá hay varios puntos lo
primero que hay que tener presente es
que la economía norteamericana ha
repuntado en el curso del último año y
se está recuperando
primero es el primer puesto cuando punto
es que el desempleo también está
en cifras muy bajas indicando que la
economía también está como decía
estirando para arriba ya que son dos
puntos positivos que cabe anotar que lo
hará ver al presidente de bailén y su
gestión económica ahora cuál es la gran
debilidad
precisamente la inflación muchos
pensaron de que eso no se iba a dar
algunos economistas como lawrence
summers advirtieron que eso podría
ocurrir si se seguía gastando como se
estaba gastando y efectivamente lo que
ha ocurrido la inflación está en su
punto más alto como sabes que en más de
más de 40 años hay medidas que se pueden
tomar una medida por ejemplo sería
eliminar los aranceles y las tarifas que
se han fijado para los productos que
vienen de china y esto yo creo que
contribuiría pero que se enfrentaría
fuerte obstáculos políticos de manera
que ese es un aspecto a considerar otra
posibilidad sería ver forma de
en el gasto fiscal pero eso es algo en
lo cual los demócratas no están
interesados ellos quieren aumentar lo
crea que las medidas técnicas económicas
que se podrían tomar enfrentan
obstáculos políticos serios de manera
que yo creo que el equipo económico del
presidente va a tener que tomar
serias medidas para ver cómo enfrenta lo
que tiene este año porque todo indica
que las elecciones de noviembre van a
ser muy difíciles para esta
administración bueno tema del cual no
podemos por supuesto dejar de hablar es
el de la pandemia de kobe 19no
cintia quisiera preguntarle a usted en
el país con más muertes sin más
contagios de todo el mundo que estamos
hablando por supuesto a eeuu como
analista la gestión de la crisis
sanitaria por parte del presidente de
joe biden principalmente en
contraposición con el exmandatario
donald trump
yo creo que el comportamiento de la
administración ha sido muy buena pero el
país es bastante
polarizado entre los que ven que una un
requerimiento de usar una mascarilla es
una violación de sus derechos humanos
entonces está esta tradición del
individualismo ha complicado mucho la
respuesta de hecho el acceso a la vacuna
es es muy muy amplia pero hay gente que
no quiere vacunarse y no quiere que sus
chicos vayan a la escuela con
mascarillas y esto
se ha puesto pues pues como una un punto
grave de división
entre los partidos políticos y que se
está usando justamente para atacar al
presidente o en entonces es un
es una en un rechazo a la ciencia a la
evidencia de que la forma de limitar la
circulación del virus es a través de
usar mascarillas y a través de la
vacunación de hecho los niveles de
contagio han bajado sustancialmente
especialmente con esa
ola terrible de omicron
las infecciones diarias son pues 10% de
lo que fueron hace dos meses
pero se critica el desempeño justamente
porque había recogido por ejemplo a las
empresas grandes que tienen cierto
número de
empleados que aplican
ese requisito también a los a la fuerza
laboral federal y hay muchos opuestos a
que el gobierno
publique a los ciudadanos de hacer cosas
que no quieren hacer
jorge cuál es su postura respecto acerca
de la gestión de la pandemia de kobe 19
por parte de bailén recién ciencia nos
hablaba de un tema nos planteaba este
tema como bastante politizado
sí yo creo lo siguiente yo creo que el
país esperaba una vez que fue electo
presidente de bailén que de alguna
manera la pandemia se pusiese casi en
forma automática bajo control que la
ciencia sería a cargo y que los
tomadores de decisiones estarían
inspirados en la ciencia y no en
caprichos como parecía que fuese antes
sin embargo como hace a la docencia la
ola de esta nueva variante micrón vino a
introducir un comodín que cambió mucho
la baraja y en ese sentido nos hemos
encontrado con la situación que ya más
de un año en el gobierno del presidente
de byd en y bueno siguen las mascarillas
y siguen los problemas de manera mucho
más suave en los números que yo he visto
indican que esto va a la baja lo que da
la esperanza que tal vez en algunos
meses el país puede entrar en otra etapa
eso está ocurriendo acá en el
massachusetts pero el tema no se despeja
y la gente está muy cansada y y hacer
una observación más antes y creo que
después de dos años de esta pandemia
esto ha tenido efectos políticos muy
serios en eeuu internamente y yo diría
que también en términos de la política
internacional lo que hemos visto es no
que las naciones se aproximen más unas a
otras que se unan para enfrentar este
tremendo desafío global sino que el
efecto ha sido el contrario lo que hemos
visto es una especie de dispersión de
disgregación de acentuación de las
contradicciones entre los países y
también el interior de los países y eso
a mí me parece muy grave yo creo que es
importante
para bajar el tono de bajar las
tensiones porque la verdad que el mundo
está en un momento muy difícil y si
sigue pues esta especie de cuesta abajo
en la rodada yo creo que vamos a
enfrentar el peligro mundial de crisis
migratoria otro de los puntos álgidos en
lo que es la situación de estados
unidos- cintia bueno hay muchos temas
para abordar este tema quisiera
preguntarle lo siguiente hay coaliciones
de organizaciones no lideradas por
migrantes que señalan ciertas
contradicciones en lo que es la política
migratoria del presidente joe biden hay
elementos que así lo afirman en cierto
punto por lo menos por ejemplo por un
lado del anuncio de la reapertura de las
fronteras de la regularización de
muchísimos de personas indocumentadas
que estaban en territorio estadounidense
por otro lado mantuvo políticas del ex
presidente de donald trump como la que
es el título 42 que tiene que ver con
una norma con la provisión del ingreso
por medidas de seguridad sanitaria por
de covite 19 también hubo otra reforma
para regularizar pero que no tuvo éxito
en el congreso encuentra usted
continuidad es y diferencias con la
política migratoria de donald trump
hay pues ambas tendencias continuidad y
cambio yo creo que la administración
está intentando hacer una política más
humanista más
dedicada a
la parte humanitaria pero lo que no lo
quiere qué
una actualización de las medidas sirven
como imán para que más migrantes vengan
a la frontera entre méxico y eeuu
entonces es una
ecuación perdida perdida no hay ninguna
condición que está a favor
del desempeño de la administración los
grupos
dedicados a la reforma de las leyes
migratorias están muy descontentos con
con el hecho de que algunas medidas como
usted señala el título 42 sigue vigente
donde la gente podría ser rechazado por
medidas por cuestiones sanitarias
pero también la dinámica política dentro
de eeuu es que igual que en otros países
especialmente en europa y más y más en
américa latina en chile en brasil en
muchas partes donde hay muchos migrantes
de venezuela o de ahí y hay un momento
en momentos de
dificultades económicas
si te perdonan tengo que interrumpió
pero nos queda poco tiempo y quisiera
conocer la opinión el balance al
respecto de este tema de la crisis
migratoria por parte de joe biden
rápidamente se lo pido jorge perdón pero
se nos está acabando el tiempo
sí yo diría dos cosas primero yo creo
que hay un punto que a mí me ha
preocupado particularmente lo hemos
conversado a conciencia que tiene que
con haití yo creo que el tema de haití y
la forma que ha sido tratado los
migrantes aquellos que han llegado desde
haití y algunos de ellos han sido
puestos aviones enviados inmediatamente
de vuelta a haití
es un tema complejo dada la situación
que está viviendo haití en el lado más
positivo diría yo y se podría decir que
sólo en forma indirecta tiene que ver
con la migración pero a mi juicio
importante ha sido la orden de detención
y extradición en contra del expresidente
de honduras juan orlando hernández
que a mi juicio le hizo un tremendo daño
a honduras y contribuyó mucho a la
crisis en honduras que llevó a esta
fuerte emigración de hondureños hacia
los eeuu y yo creo que esa es una medida
positiva si vamos a ver que llevaba a
buen puerto bueno llegamos al final de
esta emisión del debate de france 24
agradecemos muchísimo su presencia y su
participación
desde washington en eeuu y también a
jorge heine en boston también en eeuu a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a que
sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france mit y
cuatro.com sigan con nosotros
[Música]